hey folks we just received the news
moments ago that the supreme court of
the united states has now struck down
joe biden's tyrannical unconstitutional
vaccine mandate as it applies to
businesses across the country 100
million american workers were going to
be forced to vaccinate or to mask and
test every couple of days or to be fired
by their employers we are really proud
that we here at the daily wire day one
literally day one the moment that joe
biden announced this facts mandate we
said that we would not comply and we did
not comply there are a lot of other
companies that did there are a lot of
other companies that didn't have to that
decided to force their employees to mask
force their employees to vaccinate we
said you have the choice as to what you
decide to do with your own body when it
comes to this vaccine we said that from
the get-go and we're really proud of
that here at daily water but we didn't
just do that we went further we were the
first company in america to file a
federal lawsuit against the biden
administration on the basis of their
unconstitutional osha vaccine mandate it
cost us hundreds of thousands of dollars
to do this we put our money where our
mouth is because it is so important to
us that we stand up for the principles
for which you support us and that's
really the key thank you for your
support because without your support we
couldn't do stuff like this without your
support we couldn't fight the way that
we fought here and by the way this fight
had consequences for a hundred million
american workers and for the future of
governance in the united states because
if the biden administration had been
able to get away with this they could
have gotten away with pretty much
anything via the administrative state
they could have implemented tyranny top
down simply using the administrative
state they no longer can do that thanks
to the supreme court of the united
states ruling and that wouldn't have
happened without the help of people like
you so if you're already a subscriber i
want to say thank you and if you're not
already a subscriber now is the best
time ever to be a subscriber join us
because we are winning and that's why
you ought to go over to dailywire.com
subscribe and use promo code winning
that's promo code winning for 40
off your subscription today again that's
promo code winning because we are
winning we can keep winning with your
help see here's the thing
we're an organization that values
bringing you entertainment content that
you want we're an organization that
values bringing you information that you
need but most of all we're an
organization that prizes fighting
tyranny fighting authoritarianism we are
willing to stand on the front lines we
can do so with your support so again if
you already support us we really
appreciate it you made this happen if
you are about to support us we
appreciate that too please subscribe
right now dailywire.com
subscribe use promo code winning for 40
off and i can't wait to share with you
all the brand new content we are going
to make and most of all i can't wait to
fight together with you against
authoritarianism